I don't know yogi it's pretty boring hmm
this is one of those catch-22 is because
of all like the damn controversy what is
the controversy and I'm proud that I am
NOT following is the controversy that
has you know what you don't want to lead
a half like 60 something bad you know
shit no you know what it is cuz this is
I'll tell you exactly what is oh but you
tell me exactly but no we actually don't
know I'll bet a thousand bucks it went
something like this and the next thing
you know you get a whole bunch of haha
we need to see this movie it is your
god-given right duty to see this movie
to make there be beer don't wait you
don't want to see the movie you don't
want to make their pee be hurt are you
one of them check your priveledge that's
how it always works like tell me I'm
wrong tell me that's probably not how
this went down no no I followed half of
that and I'm just gonna agree with you a
ways I was angry about something or
whatever so heads up I don't know what
the controversy is I just know says some
group or two or five or whatever angry
about something why those lazy
we're just got judge it as if you read
the comments like on anything Captain
Marvel related it's one of two things
and she looks like she should go fix me
a sandwich cook in the kitchen or some
trollish shit like that or it's just
like I'm totally gonna see this movie to
stick it to you haters know so it's
gotta be the Ghostbusters that's exactly
what the sound of sounding like and
honestly this movie reminds me of that
where it's just like wow this so wasn't
even worth arguing over no oh why and
let me tell you this when I saw the
trailer fit I don't know anything about
Captain Marvel on top of she's the best
character to play in this virtual
reality Marvel game
I play and it seems like she's pretty
confident cocky she shoots fireballs and
she's like yeah kind of a big deal on
the best around it's like okay cool it
seems like movie on this character but
the trailer came out I was just like man
this looks like every Marvel movie with
nothing new at it and by god it's
absolutely oh my god yeah yeah if
anything it almost feels like things
were taken away like the car
like a lot of the comedy is taken away
is replaced with a lot of talking a lot
of creative action they should camp I
guess we got I guess if you complain
about Marvel movies being too funny this
is the one for you then like audience
was stone-cold silent 495 5 7 except at
the end when they were like yeah it was
so weird they were so quiet a tional
laugh hear that they were so quiet and
then at the very end like I don't know
it's it like some Pavlovian dog reaction
of like at the end of our movie yeah wow
like so much silence I mean ok so here's
the thing I don't think this is like a
terrible movie it's not like I was
watching going oh my god you terrible
terrible terrible movie would have been
something yeah no this was just so dull
so boring so bland so you know it's play
this takes place in the 90s cuz doesn't
this feel like a nut like a
middle-of-the-road boring 90s superhero
film that we ran out like everyone's
giving those kind of performances to
like well yeah I'm taking it seriously
but you know the kids but bomb acting
like I'm taking it seriously because you
know comic books I'm a professional like
everyone has that feel to them you know
like I'm gonna act serious
but yeah it's a comic book I know um and
I think that I want to see at the center
bike I feel like all the acting in this
it feels like it's very inconsistent yes
sometimes it's like okay that's fine and
then other times it's like real arson
has this Mila Kunis kind of quality of
just like listen it's not that I think
you're at
terrible actress it's just this is
clearly not the right no but the only
time she wonders is when when she had to
when she had to say something like kind
of cocky or funny that worked okay like
sometimes you got a laugh out of you
almost like in a Leslie Knope kind of
way it's just like okay sure by me
nothing compared to like up in Marvel
movies that are very very funny whatever
she has to be tough dramatic suspenseful
anything like that I'm like I didn't buy
a forest all my favorite point where is
kind of laughable did you did you like
the commentary by the way about like
keep your emotions in check that's like
the one I don't sick of that I am so
sick of the powers tied to the emotions
just stop that's like 1820 years old oh
oh no my favorite that was like and that
the very I wouldn't you've always liked
to keep your emotions in check emoji I
was just like were you watching this
movie Jude Law she's like had no emotion
Oh where's Lee where are these outbursts
were supposed to hear how did I even tie
into her and never seemed like you tied
into her powers you know even though
this chose been done to death it's
usually done pretty well you think of a
Kyra you think of frozen you think of
like Adventure Time like they use this
pretty well usually like it's a good
metaphor it's just been done to death
here they don't even utilize it and you
have Samuel Jackson who by God is trying
every second to get a laugh I mean he's
so he's so charming Samuel Jackson but
he is just like ma'am what can I do you
seem just like what can I do I can't
honestly tell if this is like cuz you're
right the acting is inconsistent if you
seem a directing thing everybody so I'm
like it was this a director a directing
cuz the directing was very certainly a
writing problem
yeah I've writers this thing felt light
and I'm like at the end when I was
reading the credits I was like is a
written story by whatever it's like five
separate people I'm like that makes so
much sense
wait yeah when it got to the end I was I
mean I was asking myself what is even
being fought for what is the point of
this movie because they'll say things
but I'm like but that's not what the
movies about eventually the only thing I
kind of cared about is that there's this
family in danger
I'm just saying okay I'm gonna feel bad
for a family you know whatever and but
that's about it I think this problem is
there's like two moments one when she
meets her best friend and this other
woman who plays her best friend and a
fighter pilot is like acting circles
around her and again I'm not gonna
necessarily say brie Larson is like oh
it's cuz she's a terrible act as I
haven't seen earth enough to really know
I've seen her a room and she's very
she's very good at math so I I'm not
saying but it's just so clear in that
scene it's like but this other character
is allowed to be angry to have emotion
to all these things whereas like brie
Larson plays this is like it's kind of
half like mean Hakuna Mila Kunis half
like terminator like girl termina worse
is like just robotic kind of face we're
about it kind of acting and and I'm just
like I'm like looking at this this other
woman and I'm just like she should be
Captain Marvel she's got actual most
she's not me she's in here's the thing
that she'll art Larson's credit the
characters not written the least bit
interesting nobody is written
interesting at all who is a story like
this whole story is told backwards where
they give you yeah I'm watching that's
like why am I supposed to give a shit
about this character when I know a
matter is not that interesting jumper
charming and it's out of order
they dump you basically straight into
her in the Kree homeworld as a bounty
hunter with a ton of confusing
exposition like by the knocking above
when they got to earth I'm just like you
know thank God because that van first
and then they give you all her memories
but they're like these little snippets
of memories are supposed to fill in her
like childhood and like Randa that was a
funny moment - there's that I swear to
god I'm not making this up there's like
a scene where she like is a little girl
driving a go-kart and like the go-kart
like flips over and then you see her
bloodied up like covered in smoke and
like the dad comes like
she says something like you let him
drive or something I was like did some
other kid just die like I want to know
this story more than anything no no but
don't you remember the other little kid
you know when she grows up and
everything is like yeah that's your
father you didn't get along so we became
like your second family like that
painful exposition that everybody has in
this movie so that's all you get at
least these tiny snippets after dumping
you there and then she has to piece
together how she ended up any how she
ended up on the other Creek homeworld
but like when she when the big reveals
are there like we already know this like
we're with veal no I mean that's the
thing the whole movie were 12 steps
ahead and it I I'll tell you what
bothers me there's like random scenes in
this the first scene that I remember
thinking like Oh God
was she crashes like into a it's not
really a spoiler like I think she
crashes into a blockbuster video yeah
yeah so she comes on she's asking some
security cop like we're like can I get
communications equipment I rolled my
eyes and literally thought watch it's
gonna be a RadioShack and be like points
and wah wah
RadioShack I'm like oh crap like all of
these 90s references are gonna be
painful because like you know where
they're going like oh she puts a CD in
what's going on it's loading I'm like
she's connected on the internet watch
it's gonna take Vera takes her yeah
watch it's gonna disconnect it
disconnect fresh France Joe how do I
look fresh it there is one okay but but
there's like a couple there's one joke
that works when a person on subway
reading a script I won't give it away
that was brilliant
that was fantastic then there's another
scene where like it's some kid smiles at
his father in the middle of like a
battle and I'm just like watch he's
gonna get shot he gets shot like it's
every single day even the finale when
she faces off against the villain you
know that it's not I'm not gonna make it
look like something else you know
yeah we were saying do it let me do it
and like I'm not saying that like Marvel
films are not exactly unpredictable but
this was at a level of like okay this is
kind of insulting my intelligence like
it's that it was like a bad joke right
the Marvel formula and nothing added on
top of it Marvel is usually good at
adding charming characters charming
jokes charming ideas charming visuals
and just there's not a lot of like I
like the best friend I actually like the
aliens they're trying to help
honestly the scrolls are better Green
Goblin than any Green Goblin we got any
other Marvel movie yeah yeah every one
so I mean maybe every ten minutes
I'd get a chuckle and it's not like
they're trying to make you laugh and
it's failing they're just it's doing a
lot of exposition dumps and having her
look confused to think about her past
and then that they're like telling you
what to feel half the time they're
telling it's almost like someone telling
you and then then the story this happens
and then the story this happens but
they're never letting it just happen
it's like someone's constantly telling
you what's going on and the action isn't
very impressive either and it's kind of
that shaky-cam thing the visuals or
nothing and all the effects aren't
anything that special you need effects I
really like the climax just flying
around blowing up two missiles well
can't we seen that too yeah like oh
another Canyon chase with a couple of
space yeah like all of these you like
talking about like two two scenes that
like kind of bugged me like the other
scene the other big problem is like
there's this scene where it's just like
she has to like break free and like
believe in herself or one of those
things to activate her power yeah man
that didn't feel like no that's what
kills me as I'm watching the scene it's
like it's it's her falling down
throughout her life and then getting
back up she's like a little girl like
playing baseball she steps up to bat she
she gets up after falling off you know
crashing the go car and this and then
it's like multiple scenes of her getting
up there on her in town I'm like god
this would have been so much better and
a better movie that was like what kills
me about that was like honestly the
scene itself I think is a fantastic
scene but I'm just like but we know what
she grew into
this boring bland like for all the world
powers statement in it you have to make
your character it seemed that just it
honestly wasn't until I was going in
that I I think I put not me not going in
but like maybe a few days earlier it
like it hit me like oh this is like the
first MCU female Levi's like a movie
just around a woman like it never even
count like even put on I mean what would
you think is good you want other people
trust me but but but I'm saying it
deemed it but like going in and seeing
this movie like that scene were you
seeing her constantly getting up don't
you just want to hear like a narration
say even when you fall down you get
right back up because we are strong we
are girls we are women like don't you I
just hear that narration it doesn't feel
like a legit there moment because you're
not living no you're not with any of the
characters yeah it ended at all if you
want to do that that's fine but you have
to like as I said II would have been if
this was a character that I was like
this characters amazing out follower to
the ends of the earth you know like that
scene would have been great I would have
been like what's a really inspiring seem
like I'm a sucker for a scenes like that
I love Rob she got her emotions under
control
what was that wouldn't even ever tie
into like oh no her emotions really got
her in trouble with her powers it's like
anything there's a scene like where she
could blow up in this door and she let
Samuel Jackson Lee do this whole thing
with a fingerprint and tape and he's
like you let me do that whole thing
she's like I want to see you can do like
she's unbelievably patient unbelievably
in control having the ideas the kick her
god I guess we're getting it's not
really spoilers you can pretty wanna
spoil the bed story basically was like
trying to keep her under control didn't
want it to get like too powerful for
reasons we won't get into but you know
it but I mean have you seen this done
better in so many other oh yeah it
actually ty you do those powers it was a
better metaphor it was better character
building and it's just like don't that's
the thing is I said they're like a seem
like that I'm normally a sucker for but
it's just like if you're not into the
character because there's just that much
there then it it's just a scene it's a
command that's what this movie kind of
felt there was nothing in this movie
like oh I I hate it it's awful it's not
worst thing ever no it's like honestly
that would have been something if this
were a real train wreck yeah it was
because of its third act Ghostbusters
reboot was probably a bigger train wreck
like that was fascinating to watch the
way that my third act there's a lot of
our things everything but it's the third
advert became completely unhinged all my
thank you massive watching it's almost
thinking like it's just not interesting
it's some of the x-men films it's like
this is that that's the worst thing ever
made it's just bland ya know and like
sometimes her acting is so bad that you
can make a good joke but but then other
times she can be like I said she can be
a little funny but it's like when it's
off its kind of enjoyably funny off but
it's like that about it everything else
is just soul just maybe some of the same
you know Jackson punch Alliance too but
that's about it
yeah I don't know I'll say this for
every because constantly oh I'll say it
now you like hang this up on your wall
I think DC not only did it first but did
it better Wonder Woman was a way better
movie than this oh god yeah I mean
Wonder Woman's a little is a little goes
a little bit to see what its finale but
like doesn't seem worth comparing I know
because it's so much better
no no and it's just so different - we
have one that's like you know she's from
space and she flies down you have the
one that's like an Amazon warrior in
World War two but if we are gonna
compare to the two Christ that was so
inspiring when she climbs up on that
battlefield it's all building up and
she's seeing the death around her she
doesn't make any more I mean what a
scene that there is nothing even though
I follow the character yeah yeah I'm
trying to figure out like what they're
even chasing or going after I'm like
okay I guess it's just the MacGuffin
space travel thingamajig whatever it
kind of would have been fine with
because I love the Guardians side of the
Marvel Universe whether it be Thor
Ragnarok or guardians of the galaxy
all the time I love those I love that
kind of outerspace aspect like a lot but
this one is one of the first times I'm
like this kind of dog they bring Roman
in and they don't even do anything with
him and I love ronan cuz it's just
hilarious it was big booming voice and
the way he holds her like like now they
didn't even do anything with him know
the movie I he has like seven lines I'm
like you called this guy in at the last
second and like you only give him seven
lines no the movie the DC movie I think
is worth comparing it to it's probably
Superman Returns cuz that's the one it
reminded me a lot of it's a horrible
it's about as boring yeah where it's
just like is it the worthless god-awful
it no but it's like yeah it's so boring
and it's semi it's awkward and it's a
bow and stuff yeah again if you want to
talk DC I'm looking forward a lot to
shift Sam I love talk one I mean it's
like honestly with the exception of
infinity Wars I feel like a DC's almost
like I climb and up wait they're gonna
be in the station no no it's kind of
hilarious because this was a case where
Marvel was way late to the game
yeah and getting a female superhero out
there everything about this feels you
had the best freaking line at the very
end because it it's not a spoiler so
there's a okay maybe spoiler alert but
there's a cut to a couple of the
Avengers basically and black widows fair
and you just were just like you know
she's just saying they're going ah I
guess this means we're never gonna get
to my movie a part of me is like I want
this to succeed because I know how idiot
executives think they're just like well
if this doesn't do where's cuz there was
a check you know that's gotta be why and
it's like no it's cuz it's not that good
a movie so I want to do well so I can
finally get my goddamn Black Widow movie
that's long overdue
which you know that's gonna be a better
movie that's a better character that's a
better actress that's like a better
everything and now it's like I don't
know how this is gonna do by your hand I
don't want to do well cuz I don't want
them to think okay we can really just
kind of slum it
like really kick back and like not try
that much is like no what you really
really got a key problem is like
particularly coming out of like into the
spider-verse
freaking spider-gwen I thought had a lot
more character that and she's not even
the main character I mean it almost
doesn't feel and it's fair to compare it
to like other like female heroes or
whatever cuz it just seems like this
wasn't that like just so far behind and
not even like no this movie played it is
something from the 90s like it really
feels like a boring bland 90s movie so
maybe that was the intention
maybe it's brilliant if it takes place
in the night what you want to see a good
female film like we could go see battle
angel Aleta please yeah that's what
kills me everybody was arguing over it's
like agenda this movie has agendas in
this Annette and this movie gets all the
attention and then Aleta just came and
went because people were just like
bitching about this movie and I'm like
meanwhile you had a great movie like a
leader just sitting there collecting
which was time yeah which has like yes
yeah well creative had no effect with it
was so like grand big and you liked
everybody and they were so enjoyable it
was kind of new stuff you never see on
the big screen before and it was
charming and it was clever it's just
like and they just had this which is
really just Marvel's table scraps you
know and it's it still Marvel's table
scraps they made a lot of good movies so
it's like I mean if anything it is kind
of like wow it's not often we get to
shit on a Marvel movie honestly it's
like Thor the dark world why I guess the
Iron Man oh yeah I still can't even
remember Mickey Rourke with electric
yeah and a parent that's our Barrett
Incredible Hulk was me but that's that's
kind of the big criticism it's like I'm
saying or yeah that wasn't very good
it's like this is our first like and
even this is an awful not I mean it's
not like the worst it's just very bland
forgettable honestly can we haven't seen
obviously any Marvel movies that come
out after this but I mean can you even
guess anything that's like no you need
to see this to see the upcoming Marvel
films like did anything in it even feel
like super connected to the Marvel just
to Captain Marvel is because they're
basically like Anna
we're in yeah but but it's like no
development I mean it's like I feel like
what I'm super worried because they're
making it look like oh yeah she's gonna
be the one to to get the Avengers like
back together and and I wanted to be her
what a lame character I'm just like
really like her like I'm so hoping
through this movie I'm just like like
this is the problem though when you like
Bank like this is where and the problem
is like Black Panther had the opposite
problem where I don't think they
realized how huge that one was gonna be
so like a lot of people complained not
enough Black Panther stuff in infinity
war 1 this might be one where I'm like
there's gonna be too much Captain Marvel
and infinity more to maybe you know I
mean that my hope is that maybe it was
like just a directing issue like maybe
there were two directors maybe so maybe
that's it maybe one who directors a live
writer yes I make it more funny in the
air is like no make it more serious and
like even they didn't know me to pull a
better perform yeah that's what I'm
hoping and they can do something more
interesting with Erica if they got this
was boring yeah yeah it this was just so
boring
it sucks to it like and this is what
bothered me about Ghostbusters the the
reboot which is when the culture wars
make it so much about like this has to
sink or swim because it's empowering
girls everywhere and you don't make a
good movie you've done girls a huge
disservice like that that's what bothers
no I it that's why it really shouldn't
be about that you should just good
filmmakers they have gotta make good
films so it's just like you know if you
miss it you're just gonna look like the
dorky one out you know I which Marvel
has head hit after hit but if like if
you don't nail this and you're like oh
well that's the reason it failed that
then you're gonna look like the schmuck
and everyone else is gonna go and create
these really cool movies and again
you're gonna be behind so I don't know
it really might be about like making a
good yeah just make a good movie like
you know is don't be like what we can
just hand the table scraps over to this
one it's like no you gotta make it good
marvel's usually usually pretty good at
that but yeah this one was very bland
very bored they made a good movie with
black panther I mean that's the other
thing here's what what feels so
I guess that's partially some of what
bothers me about like it was like oh
yeah it's so amazing captain marvel
females severe I'm like we already had
Aleta we've done it with Wonder Woman I
mean I get its Mar again it's kind of
late yeah I just feel like okay who
cares yeah why is like I said it didn't
even really dawn on me until like
everybody's wait you know arguing probe
for or against the movie and I'm just
like why are you even arguing this one
we're like so down like the list of like
like DC already did it and just wait
till it comes out you know whatever you
could be getting behind something that's
really stupid people were getting Jar
Jar tattoos when Phantom Menace was
coming out now they feel like July I
want you anime all the time I see strong
female characters a lot so ya know I
mean it's if they're gonna be late to
the game to gonna be late to the game
but don't add that well it's it's sold
it's good because there's a female lead
it's like look it could still be shit
and this is again this is like the worst
it's just so boring and investing so
much in the culture war side of it just
leads to disaster because it's just
ironic cuz we're talking quite a bit I
want this shit stop I'm sick of like I
just want to go see a movie like I'm
like at what point does this bottomed
out at what point does the internet just
go okay maybe we should just get a life
yeah at what point you know it's just
all these keyboard warriors and I'm just
like Jesus just go see the movie the
best thing Rotten Tomatoes did was
ditching that whole like audience score
before the movies even release cuz they
were they've been weaponizing then I
always thought it was stupid anyway cuz
I'm like what is this even calculating
like do I want to see it
the percentage like well the bright talk
about pre-screens which even then lots
of no not even pre screenings like the
trailer would come out like six months
ahead of time and like it would have an
audience score already of like I guess
it's like the percentage of time yeah
yeah I guess it doesn't release the same
time the critics then again I guess I
never I don't really get that upset
about audience scores because I never
pay
attention to them anyway no I'm like
that doesn't mean jack shit but with
that said again I mean the last time I
looked I mean maybe it's going down but
like I saw like 88% and I I don't get
that at all yeah I I don't yeah
also tabulate how many people actually
voted like that's what drives me nuts
about this is like okay so it's a very
small percentage of the country that
votes on this like that doesn't tell you
anything it just tells you who's
enthused and for what reason like you're
either a lover or a hater and it's
because if you're gonna take the time to
even bother doing that you got to be
passionate about it one way or another
and that's why I'm like I did don't I
don't pay attention like if you went my
audience scores that particularly on
IMDB even God it's hilarious what some
of the higher rated ones are and it's
like really like that movie when again
Emmy we should reiterate we don't know
what the controversy behind this movie
is if we could say this thing and then
like you'd be like oh it was something
totally different way but I feel like it
was something bigger we would have heard
about it but it's still like it's
probably yeah all I know is I just roles
attacking Captain Marvel and oh you
should go see Captain Marvel maybe it is
that but I always I don't know it's
always some variation of it yeah I guess
I can say if you saw cuz I saw the
trailer for this I wasn't excited I
thought the only scene I thought cool
was when she punches the old lady I'm
like what leads to that but aside from
that like I didn't think it was very it
looks very interesting and but but
people I mean some people they applauded
at the answer like my guess is I wasn't
super shoes but if you look at the
trailer and you're like yeah that looks
like fun I I guess that that's you get
that and nobody really much like I've
kind of given up on trailers just cuz
I've been burned so many times and one's
a movie so I thought we're gonna be
great by the trailer and they're not or
movies that I thought well that's gonna
suck and actually ended up being really
good Elite is a great example it's like
this is gonna
hated that trailer hated it and like I'm
just like I was frickin wrong go see
Lolita yes please instead of this I want
more Lita movies than Captain Marvel
movies um so yeah bottom line when the
most emotional part of your movie is the
opening logo and the cat cats the
funniest part your movies probably in
trouble so uh we didn't like it
we thought it was pretty dull I don't
know what everyone else is thinking but
I yet did not win those over it's like I
can't even it's hard to even say I can't
get angry yeah if I say I didn't like it
that means I had an emotion I need to
keep my emotions and you had no impact
how about that ya know it just in the in
one ear out the other
it's like yeah just I hope she Sam is
good funny uh aquaman was good Wonder
Woman's got me I'm hope I'm are we gonna
get a black widow movie eventually I I
always hear them talk about it I'm over
if it's happening but it would be
interesting the kind of switch of Marvel
star going down at DC started coming up
that's best world would be if they're
both great I mean what you for that I
guess yeah no I would rather actually
baby both yeah I like them both I won't
lie it is starting to get kind of that
vibe of just like DC maybe learn a
lesson finally like and this this was
this was a big slip up I think of
Marvel's part and not only just that the
movies bland but to be this late to the
game yeah and then and yet pat
themselves on the back like they did in
the middle I think we did it I'm like
everybody else's beat you to it like
yeah so
fury road beat them to yeah ladies beat
them to it I mean that tons and what 90
lots be opium to it so um yeah that's
about it a lot of movies are coming out
say probably I see us a lot more uh yeah
yeah yeah well we've been spring yeah
just a lot of movies are coming out so
we're gonna try our best to keep up with
them if we get to them late we'll just
get to them late we'll still drag them
out there so uh that's why then see you
next time take care
go see you later please
singles it did well in China he'll
probably do see I want to see close
you